-John, it is always such
a delight to see you.
-Hi, Seth! You look so gorgeous.
-Thank you so much.
That means a lot
coming from you,
because I don't know if
you're aware of this --
I've been -- You know,
I've been forced into doin
my own makeup during quarantine.
-See, I was going to ask, if -
Are you --
I just assumed that was, like,
a light moisturizer,
which is a sign of good makeup
-Thank you.
See, I feel very --
That means the world to me
But there is a little powder
-Yeah.
-There's a little foundation
And I just feel
a little better every day.
And I cannot tell you how much
genuine pride I take from it
-It's so gorgeous.
You know, men, we're socialize
to think that that's gay
to put on makeup.
And it, of course, is.
I want to be clear.
But, you know,
there is a real pleasure in it
-Well, I think it is
a reminder that a lot of thing
we think were gay, gay is ofte
just a synonym for better.
Like, I just look -- To look gay
is to look just, like, bette
than the way you would loo
if you were resistant to thing
that were historically
stereotyped.
-Yeah, so put an ounce of
thought into your appearance
-Yeah, if you just think
a little bit about
your appearance,
you will look better.
-I have to say, like,
it must be acknowledged
that even
through 3,000 miles apart,
the sexual chemistry
is off the charts.
I mean, even with
Zoom, we are -- It's electric.
It's crazy.
-Well, it's interesting,
because I feel like
it's electric when
we're face-to-face.
-Of course.
-And, yet, now, of course,
we're more reliant
on actual electricity because of
the way we're communicating.
-Right.
-And so it's -- It may be, like,
a factor of two.
-Right, right.
-Yeah.
I'm glad --
-What's "The Thorn Birds"?
I'm sorry.
What's "The Thorn Birds"?
-"The Thorn Birds" is --
It turns out
most attics in the Northeast
just have it.
It's like this...
But have you been reading?
-I have been reading.
-You been using
quarantine to read?
-Like, it started very --
It started as
a performance for sure.
Like, it was very --
I was, like,
on the porch, like,
in wartimes,
like, you know, "reading,"
but then, actually,
it became reading.
-Mm-hmm.
-And, yeah, you know,
there's kind of --
We have no other choice,
but, like, it has been so nice
And then, like, again, it's kind
of goes on the list of, like
you know, I've been making
"sourdough bread."
It's like it's annoying
to talk about,
but once you kind of get ove
it, like, it is -- it's so nice.
It's so nice to have your brai
going one direction
for a long period of time
versus 14 at all times
via the Internet.
-It's really nice.
Also, I do find --
I am aware that I'm doing it
When I'm reading a book that
I really like, I will --
I know it sounds braggy,
but I do want to
talk about it to people.
I want them to read it
so that we can talk about it
-I know.
But it's so crazy to, like
ask someone to do somethin
that takes days, like, casually.
-But we suggest
television shows that --
You know when you, like,
get a book on Kindle,
sometimes, it will say,
"This takes five hours to read."
-I don't have Kindle, Seth
-Five hours?!
-What?
-I don't have a Kindle, Seth
-I noticed you framed
your bookshelf, John.
-[ Laughs ]
Oops!
-But you have watched
television, as well?
-I've watched so much
"Top Chef."
I've never seen --
I've never watched "Top Chef
until this moment.
It's become like
a true Binky, like,
after a certain point of night
I've literally --
I've Googled so many times
at like 2:00 in the morning,
"Are Gail and Padma friends?
-And are they?
For those who
don't have time to Google.
-You know, I haven't found
any conspiracy theories.
I mean, again, like us,
the chemistry I feel
between them is electric.
-It would be hard to fake.
-It would be -- Yeah, it would
be hard for it to be fake.
But, like, I'm -- Just, like
any time they interact,
like, any comment across
the judges's table,
I, like,
literally start blushing.
I'm wildly in love with them